by the way did you guys hear about what
Twitter just did no did you hear the
news about Twitter time or no uh like
this morning it's not breaking this is
this is the the amount of employees now
they have based on CNBC Rob I think I
may have even texted you this
type in type and see a typing there you
go right there click on that right there
Twitter Tom look at this tell me this
isn't crazy Twitter is now down to fewer
than 550
Engineers what Twitter so zoom in a
little bit internal records show that
Twitter has shed about 80 of its
employees in salamos took over wow head
count is hover around 1300 full-time
employees today with fewer than 550
full-time Engineers one former Twitter
engineer says that the remaining team
will be spread thin and will likely have
a hard time maintaining the service
while adding new features in addition to
1300 full-time employees the new owner
Co Elon Musk has authorized about 130
people from its own other companies
including Tesla SpaceX and a boring
company to work for the social media
business wow think about that when you
create a unique culture question came
about
uh on one of the masterminds we were
doing this week a guy says you know
matter of fact no it was actually a
conversation I was having yesterday with
a good friend a guy says you know what
do you do in a situation like this when
you're taking over a company and you're
Elon okay do you fire everybody they
don't like working for a guy like you
where you don't you're not letting
people work from home you want people to
be there every day you want people
driving and all of a sudden like they
see you as a dictator Elon they don't
see you as a what's the word a uh
understanding compassionate empathetic
you know somebody who values lowering
anxiety and all this stuff listen
anxiety if you are afraid of anxiety and
and mental issues you go through don't
join a startup on don't work for a
Founder let me say that one more time if
you're worried about your anxiety never
work for a Founder never be part of a
startup go work for a big company that
nobody knows what the hell you're doing
when you leave work if you leave Friday
at 2 30 nobody knows not a big company
at a small company you leave work at 2
30. everybody knows when you leave out 2
30. some people don't like that but you
know what else is the benefit of working
with a guy like Elon here's what happens
when you work with a guy like Elon five
ten years later when there is a go in
public opportunity or an experience like
that and you're sitting there saying did
you see how much money just simply
counted these people now we're like
regular people that that's like a big
check yeah but don't act like you're
worth it yeah so this is a great meeting
where Paul wanted to give you my
feedback about what's taking place here
nothing to say here but you have to you
have to I asked Peter I said Peter you
ever worked with a crazy founder before
not like this ever seen something like
this I'm like well that's what's going
to take so it's not for everybody hey if
you enjoyed this short Club you want to
watch the whole thing click over here
but if you want to make 2023 the
beginning of the greatest years of your
life I host a conference once year it's
called The Vault conference where 3 000
CEOs executive entrepreneurs from around
the world come together to strategize
for three and a half days this year it's
going to be at Miami Diplomat Resort and
the speakers this year is going to be
Tom Brady he'll be there I'll be
interviewing them Mike Tyson will
guidera the guy that ran 11 Madison in
New York if you run a business if you're
a CEO entrepreneur and executive this is
not an event you want to miss out on get
yourself your spouse your business
partner your running mates registered
and I look forward to seeing you there
click on the link here or see the link
in the description and I hope to spend
three and a half days with you in Miami
in August and September take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]